-Republicans are standing
in the way
of urgently needed action
to take on the real world
effects of climate change,
even after the destruction
wrought by Hurricane Ida
and at the same time,
they´re also staging a stunning
and brazen attack on
Roe v. Wade with the help
of conservatives
on the Supreme Court.
For more on this,
it´s time for "A Closer Look."
Well, last week was
a real bad news parade
and we were off,
which means
I didn´t have
the catharsis of the show
to vent all my outrage,
making matters worse,
I spent the week at my least
favorite place on earth,
the beach, where not only
was I hot and sandy,
but my kids were giving me hell
because I didn´t bring
the right plastic shovels
they liked.
And I´m like,
what´s wrong with this shovel?
And they said,
we like the green ones.
And I said, well,
I like staying inside
and doing the "New York Times"
spelling bee,
so we don´t always get
what we want.
And then they said,
you´re stupid.
And I said, stupid, actually,
three out of seven days,
I´m a genius.
And when I´m not,
it´s because of some dumbass
not a word pangram
like jouncing.
Anyway, and these days,
you don´t have to look very far
for bad news.
Here in New York City,
the destruction of Hurricane Ida
was so bad, they were
practically rivers pouring
into people´s homes and cars
floating in five feet of water.
The flooding was so bad
the subway
looked like a white water rapid.
I was waiting for an F train
and instead,
an MTA canoe pulled up,
and even that had a guy
with a bike taking up space.
It´s undeniable,
as it has been for a long time,
that climate change
is intensifying these storms
and having deadly
real world impacts right now,
as we can see in front of us
with our own eyes,
much of the West
has been on fire this summer.
Wildfire smoke has drifted
all the way across the country
and made the air toxic on
the East Coast.
And New York City
just had to declare its first
ever flash flood emergency.
It´s getting so bad
that pizza rat
has taken up water ballet,
and I hope, I just hope,
it waited a half hour
after eating.
He looks great because
he ate a lot of pizza
and he didn´t look great,
but now he´s swimming.
He looks great.
And yet, as they were airing
a press conference
with local officials
discussing storm damage,
the supposed news side
of Fox News cut away
and dismissed any discussion
of climate change as quote,
"political."
-Because of climate change
and these record storms,
storms that were once
in 500 years, I´m told.
Now that we´ve got
a look at them to be storms
that come in a regular manner
more intense, as indicated.
And so I want to thank --
I spoke to Speaker Pelosi
to make sure that we work very
closely with Senator Schumer.
So there´s no separation between
the House and the Senate.
And I think all of the members
of the United States Congress
and bringing the resources here
to the City of New York.
Let me thank the mayor
and the governor
for their working
on this instantaneously.
-This has turned politically
quite quickly.
It didn´t take long to put
the focus on
"climate change."
-That´s Fox,
quote unquote news.
We´re way past the quote unquote
part of climate change.
Americans are dealing
with unprecedented
flooding and deadly wildfires
intensified by climate change,
and you guys sounds like parents
trying to understand TikTok.
My kids keep filming themselves
singing sea shanties
in their bedroom.
I guess they´re trying
to go quote unquote viral,
but it´s not just these
anti-science reactionaries
we have to contend with.
There are also the so-called
moderate Democrats
standing in the way
of major climate legislation
like West Virginia
Senator Joe Manchin,
who recently announced that
he won´t support the Democrats
$3.5 trillion spending bill that
contains, among other things,
significant investments
in climate infrastructure.
-Moderate Democrat Senator
Joe Manchin
is urging fellow Democrats
to hit the pause button
on that $3.5 trillion
spending bill,
saying there are more
urgent priorities.
-Manchin in the past has already
raised concerns
about the price tag,
but now he is raising concerns
about the timing,
and that could throw the wrench
in this process
and could upend efforts
to pass this,
as well as a separate
$1.2 trillion
infrastructure plan.
Just moments ago,
he wrote in an op-ed
in "The Wall Street Journal,"
instead of rushing to spend
trillions
on new government programs
and additional
stimulus funding,
Congress should hit
a strategic pause.
-First of all, what would
a pause look like
on Capitol Hill, a place where
it takes longer to pass
a single piece of legislation
than it takes to get
a third season of "Succession"?
And don´t get me wrong,
I cannot wait
for a new season of
"Succession."
I just worry when Logan Roy
has more time to scheme.
Oh.
Dad?
Second, you want to pause
on legislation that would,
among other things,
expand health care
amid a once-in-a-century
pandemic,
invest in job
creating infrastructure
amid an unemployment crisis,
and address climate change
amid unprecedented
floods and fires?
You really think now
is the time for a pause?
You´re like the guy
in the zombie movie
who thinks everyone should stop
running toward the military base
and instead just hide out
in the shed.
Guys, I know zombies.
They´re not going to come
into the shed.
Now which one of you
is shuffling and moaning?
Oh, no! I´m sorry,
you don´t get to take a pause
when the stakes are this high.
Although I guess you don´t have
to worry about rising sea levels
when your house is a boat.
-Your profile of Manchin
it´s got a lot of really
interesting details.
Not the least of which
is that the senator lives
on the Potomac River
in a houseboat
named after
a John Denver lyric.
-Back in March,
Ron Klain, the chief of staff
of the White House,
went to dinner
with Joe Manchin.
One thing I discovered
during the reporting
went to visit him
on that houseboat.
They had dinner,
and during the dinner,
President Biden called
and said,
you know, when are you
inviting me out there?
-Why does the senator
have a houseboat?
Houseboats are for cops
who play by their own rules
and drink whiskey
from the bottle
while looking at a framed photo
of their ex-wife.
Oh, sure, she´s with
that fancy lawyer now,
but I bet she still thinks
about you all the time.
God, you guys sure
had some good times.
Oh, oh, you fought like
cats and dogs.
But damnit, she could
always find the pangram.
You jounce my heart, Sheila.
Also, Lindsey Graham
was reportedly on the boat
before he was diagnosed
with COVID and COVID aside,
I can´t think of anything
less appealing
than being trapped on
a houseboat with Lindsey Graham.
If you ever find my body
floating in the East River,
It was one or two things.
Either the mob
put a hit out on me
for making too many jokes
about the Mets,
or I was on a houseboat
with Lindsey Graham
and swimming home
was the only other option.
Where are you going?
I was just about
to crack open a sarsaparilla
and tell you about the time
I was voted most polite
at the Meemaw Awards.
It´s an award voted on
and presented by my meemaw.
I usually sweep
the major categories.
Splash!
The nation faces a series
of massive existential crises
brewing all at once,
and we can´t just sit around
and wait for one guy
in a houseboat
to decide whether he wants
to do something about it.
Whether it´s the pandemic,
climate change, democracy itself
or the right´s intensifying
assault on Roe v. Wade,
which took
a horrifying turn last week
when the Supreme Court
in the dead of night
upheld a heinous and truly
diabolical law in Texas
that bans abortions
in brazen defiance
of Supreme Court precedent
and the Constitution.
-In the dead of night,
they did it
in the dead of night,
five Republican Supreme
Court justices,
including three appointed
by Donald Trump,
a man who lost
the popular vote in 2016
by nearly three million votes.
They destroyed a woman´s
right to bodily autonomy
and reproductive choice.
First in the state of Texas,
but who knows what´s next?
And they did it shortly
before midnight.
No big public announcement
with an order
that is barely more
than a page long.
-That´s right, they did it
in the dead of the night
in little more than a page.
The same way a rich kid
half asses
a freshman English paper
because he knows he can´t
fail out.
The font is size 16.
The margins are two inches
on each side,
and at one point you claim
"Beowulf is about a wolf
"who lives by the bay
on a houseboat like my dad
the senator."
A-minus?
Also, three of the five justices
who wrote this odious
and contemptuous ruling
were appointed by a deeply
unpopular one-term president
who lost the popular vote
by three million.
They gutted a woman´s
right to choose in Texas,
and who knows where else next
despite never
commanding majority support
from the American people,
And they don´t give a [bleep]
because they´re there for life.
I mean, if that´s how our
government is going to work,
then why not just
have a [bleep] monarchy?
At least then we´d have
more messy tabloid drama
and a Netflix show
called "The Gavel,"
where the men get played
by actors who are way better
looking than the actual royals.
I mean, I´m sorry,
but Prince Charles being played
by Dominic West?
Who´s your casting director?
Prince Charles?
Another option, of course,
is putting fake ears
on Ryan Gosling,
would that work?
I mean, how much clearer
can it get
that our democracy in fire
and that we desperately need
far reaching changes
like Supreme Court reform,
eliminating
the Electoral College,
banning gerrymandering,
and radically expanding
voting rights.
And just to underscore
the point
the dissents
from liberal justices
were righteous in their fury
and accurately captured
just how reckless and grotesque
this ruling was.
-Sonia Sotomayor wrote
a scathing dissent
that reads this way,
"The Court´s order is stunning.
"Presented with an application
"to enjoin a flagrantly
unconstitutional law engineered
"to prohibit women
from exercising
"their constitutional rights
"and evade judicial scrutiny,
a majority of justices
have opted to bury
their heads in the sand."
-"In effect,
the Texas Legislature
"has deputized
the state citizens
"as bounty hunters,
offering them cash prizes
for severely prosecuting their
neighbors´ medical procedures."
-I mean,
they´re obviously right.
In fact, here´s a clue as to
how insane this Texas law is.
You never want to see
the words "bounty hunters"
and "cash prizes"
in a Supreme Court document.
You want to see them in a 1987
Arnold Schwarzenegger
movie called "Money Hunt."
"The only way I can get
the money for my wife´s surgery
"is if I capture Delgado.
"Where are you hiding, Delgado!
You´re on a houseboat?
You in the shed?"
As the dissenters explain,
the conservative majority
of the Supreme Court
basically just laid out
a roadmap
for how you can get
around constitutional
right they don´t like,
in this case,
a woman´s right to bodily
autonomy and reproductive choice
just let citizens
do the dirty work.
It´s insane. Something tells me
those same five justices
would never let such a law stand
for, say, the Second Amendment.
Imagine if a blue state
like New York and California
passed a law
allowing any citizen to sue
any other citizen for buying
or intending to buy a gun?
I mean, how would
that even work?
You´d have to go
to someone´s house
and serve them with a lawsuit
knowing they just bought a gun.
I don´t even like knocking
on a neighbor´s door
when I´m friends with them.
One time my kids chucked
a frisbee in a neighbor´s yard
instead of asking for it back,
I just told them
to learn a different sport.
They´re getting
into baseball now.
Even though it´s only been
a couple of weeks,
they´re already better with men
on base than the Yankees.
That´s right! The Yankees
are the new Mets.
Party´s over, Wally.
Oh, you had your fun, Wally,
you had your fun,
but the party´s over, Wally.
Seriously, though,
the blue states,
you just go ahead and do it.
Just write a Texas-style law
but for guns,
they´re supporting
Trump online or whatever.
Just [bleep] put
the conservatives on the court
and expose
their bad faith [bleep].
I´m guessing Kavanaugh
would have another ´80s
movie villain temper tantrum,
where he looks like
the vice principal
telling Michael J. Fox
that Wolf can´t play basketball.
Delgado!
And of course, we were assured
repeatedly by the same
bad faith liars
who always lie to justify
their cowardice
that this day
would never come.
It would never come.
Like Maine Senator
Susan Collins.
-How can you be, or are you
100% certain?
Without a doubt
that Brett Kavanaugh
will not overturn
Roe v. Wade.
-I do not believe
that Brett Kavanaugh
will overturn Roe v. Wade.
-These precedents were
overturned all the time.
-They aren´t overturned
all the time.
And listen to the standards
that he put forth
in his conversation with me
and also in the hearing.
He says for a precedent,
a long established precedent
like Roe to be overturned,
it would have to have
been grievously wrong
and deeply inconsistent.
He noted that Roe
had been reaffirmed
19 years later
by Planned Parenthood vs. Casey
and that it was precedent
on precedent.
He said it should be extremely
rare that it be overturned
and it should be and say --
-And you have obviously
full confidence.
-I do.
-If you ever see Susan Collins
on your TV
telling you it´s going to be
80 degrees and sunny out,
grab that umbrella.
And among the many horrifying
and heinous aspects of this bill
is the fact that
the Texas lawmakers behind it
can´t even defend its abject
cruelty without making it clear
they don´t know what the hell
they´re talking about.
For example, the law doesn´t
even provide
exceptions for rape or incest.
When he was asked about
that yesterday,
Governor Greg Abbott
claimed the bill
supposedly allows six weeks
to get an abortion,
a response that was
so vile and moronic
it was left to Congresswomen
Alexandria Ocasio-Cortez
to explain
how basic biology works.
-I find Governor Abbott´s
comments disgusting,
and I think there´s twofold.
One, I don´t know
if he is familiar
with a menstruating
person´s body.
In fact, I do know
that he´s not familiar
with a woman -- with a female
or menstruating person´s body,
because if he did, he would know
that you don´t have six weeks.
Is that quote unquote
"six weeks,"
And I´m sorry,
we have to break it down --
you know, break down Biology 101
on national television,
but in case no one has informed
him before in our life,
in his life,
six weeks pregnant
means two weeks late
for your period.
And two weeks late
on your period
for any person, any person
with a menstrual cycle
can happen if you´re stressed,
if your diet changes,
or for really
no reason at all.
So you don´t have six weeks,
that´s first things first.
-It´s a shame that it´s even
necessary for AOC
to have to explain biology 101
on national television,
but she is very good at it.
I wish she´d been
my high school math teacher.
Then maybe I´d know
what the [bleep] fractal is.
Even though
I´m getting through life
just fine, Mr. McKinley,
your worst warnings vis-a-vis me
and my lack of understanding
of fractals
have not come to pass.
I´m thriving!
Seriously, though,
I get that these guys
are just unrepentant
misogynists
who want to control
women´s bodies,
but they can´t even be bothered
to pay attention
for five minutes
in health class?
Do we also need
members of Congress
to go on TV
and teach driver´s ED?
Does AOC need to get
in the car with Ted Cruz
and teach him
how to parallel park?
I´m guessing that dude´s
never done a K-turn in his life.
Of course, Republicans
only do R-turns
where they drive straight ahead,
turn around in a circle,
crash into a parked car,
and then drive away
and say it was...
[ speaks indistinctly ]
Sometimes the graphics don´t --
they´re just not ready
early enough in the day
for me to see them so.
We see them at the first
time when you guys did.
They did a hell
of a job, though.
They did a hell of a job.
We´re facing a series of
simultaneous substantial crises
that are all brewing
at the same time.
There´s a political movement
in this country
trying to halt any progress
in tackling climate change
while shredding women´s
reproductive rights.
We need urgent,
far reaching reforms
that enshrine a woman´s
right to choose in federal law,
expand voting rights,
and address climate change.
And those reforms need to happen
in the Senate and House
as opposed to a senator´s...
-Houseboat.
This has been
"A Closer Look."
God´s Love We Deliver cooks
and brings over two million
meals a year
to men, women, and children
living with HIV/AIDS,
cancer,
and other serious illnesses,
and they need your help
now more than ever.
If you´re watching this online,
you can hit the donate button.
Stay safe. Get vaccinated.
We love you.